[Music]
my name is
artem ameroff i'm the owner of royal
gloss
restoration studio here in russia and
i'm the
head restoration artist there today i'm
going to walk you through how we
restored this
42 000 celine crocodile bag it was
made around eight years ago and they
were producing it for one year only
this makes it really rare there was a
huge amount of problems on it there was
a
scuffs and scratches all over the back
the lining inside the bag was completely
messed up
the bag was missing the puller for the
zipper
[Music]
we start with removing the edge paint
all the edges of the back have scuffs
and scratches
we use the grinder to sand it down
we begin with disassembling the back
[Music]
the inner lining had a lot of scratches
from active fuse as well it had some
dirt stains
to clean and fixed the inner lining we
had to pull apart
all the back
the tools that we used were a seam
reaper and a cobbler knife
the seam ripper is more preferred for
delicate parts of the back
[Music]
we carefully slide under the stitch and
pull the
stitch upward to get it out
[Music]
the original lining for celine crocodile
back is made of sheepskin
we also use shipskin with the same
quality with the same color
and the same softness after we carefully
took off all the
sheepskin linings from each side of the
back we replaced them with the new ones
[Music]
to cut the new lining out we use a
rotary cutter
[Music]
the glue that we use is the same that
the manufacturer use
[Music]
it has a very strong bonding
[Music]
in order to make a new zipper for our
bag we use the new
zipper we use new leather
we choose a pattern to match the
original scales and we painted the same
color as the back
in order to clean the handbag we use a
special leather shampoo
and a semi-soft brush
when we talk about cleaning the
crocodile skin it is difficult because
you can damage the patina
even with a mild cleaner you can just
wipe it out
[Music]
one of the beacons concerns is the
scales which cracked on the
handle if it's not prevented in time
later it will be very difficult to
repair them
it's also had greasy stains on it so in
order to remove
the stains and for a paint to penetrate
through the
handle and to have a bond with the
surface
we need to use acetone to remove the
greasy stains applying an edge paint
coat is essential part to keep
all the edges sealed and prevent the
back from further moisture penetration
to apply the edge paint we use a special
roller pen
it grabs a certain amount of edge paint
and
allows to allocate it to the edges
in order to color match i'm testing
colors on separate
crocodile leather skin
i am trying to mimic the fading that
goes from the center to the edges
from blue to dark blue and then to the
black it gives back a very unique look
in order to apply the paint i'm using
airbrush
and small spray gun working with them
allows me to accurately distribute paint
all over the surface
we use water-based paints which will
cover up all the defects
these kinds of paints have a great
adhesion properties
[Music]
we had two types of sewing machines to
get the same old stitch holes
we regulate the length between the holes
one of the sewing machines was primarily
used to sew the
thickest part of the ladder
we had to be careful with uh assembling
the back back together
because while assembling all the sides
of the back we had to consider the
thickness of the leather layers
so they won't move during this sewing
process
for some parts we did a hand sewing to
avoid damaging the crocodile leather
[Music]
you